[Music]
WK + z the dutch station
mad flavor here in the Garden of Good
and Evil [__] uncle Joey coming
direct at you all you see is a head and
some [__] grass but who gives a [__]
jack at least it's a real setting you
know I'm satisfying some setting of me
like waterfalls and [__] like that
what's happening you bad [__]
so beautiful day to be alive you got the
world by the balls and nobody can say
dick TM Santa's the world although you
dick can you don't know them big ain't
no prison for debtors [__]
so keep movin cuz it's [__] Wednesday
we got a podcast at 8 o'clock the
afternoon early today but Joey enough
with the chitty-chat oh I smoke this
[__] wreath even talking about all
this [__] sky walk it is deadly
deadly understand
a place to smoke the best little my eyes
I got a conference call at 12:00 I'm
gonna do some kettlebells maybe jump a
little rope on my fat [__] ass and
that's it I got a podcast and I don't
know what the [__] I'm gonna do but what
we got is he will hear right now don't
forget the special comes out I see so
Joey Diaz socially unacceptable that's
what I am I'm socially unacceptable but
I know that Garnett I don't give a [__]
comes out December 8th don't see so what
you're gonna do is I'm gonna give you
the special for free
you're gonna go to see so TV and you're
gonna [__] type in Joey and you're
gonna get too much of the free December
8th that comes up my specialty feels
free who's better than [__] you
nobody talks like this I worked hard on
this thing for you [__] I want
to make you proud I'm saying anybody
wasn't fed me or let me sleep on their
[__] floor this is for you person
and beside that Trump is present all
right accept it
did I vote I can't vote would I have
voted not really I'm not gonna lie to
you people I'm a [__] loser but at
least I know that going and that's the
most important thing knowing the hero
loser going him but you got balls of
steel in our heart that won't [__]
quit okay
so accept it you have to go have time
and walk and protest they know future of
protest you know it's a fusion but they
leave it off ten 40k there's nothing you
know the future is a [__] back to the
head and spray mace di boss that's the
future and program you become something
awesome I'm a coffee man at Starbucks
now whenever they [__] call himself a
barista at the flop patty for making
coffee [__] before I stab me in
the womb
and it's on anyway it's time for bug
number 2 cos we don't [__] around you
know I'm saying it's a beautiful day the
sun's out the birds are chirping and
most importantly you're alive do
something with it justify your [__]
life you're gonna sit there
Trump is present they don't like women
this second gives a [__]
then he grabbed your [__] shut the [__]
up get up put your stockings on if you
put stockings on nobody can get deep
into your monkey I'm saying they gotta
do [__] but your stockings on and get
out there and get out there stop your
[__] away well women little girls and
no self-esteem what the [__] are you
talking about you were sucking victim a
garage when [__] Reagan was president
anyone talk about self-esteem what's
wrong with these [__] people for
everything an excuse for [__] every
down gives a [__] were you scared
you don't think I'm scared of this the
devil that's it and I he comes by every
[__] night - [__] them what I was my
only fear prison I did it it stitches in
the head I [__] him dead it knives to
my throat [__] people with burns I
didn't the Trump is gonna scare I'm
leaving the country and the airport is
[__] empty when I land this fund I
didn't see none these [__] so my
buddies down there waiting for will we
even [__] you
it's [__] coffee and shadow you
[__] Momo's Joey you're getting a
motion for your blood pressure
in my world can't be emotional that's
all you got emotions got balls and
[__] heart and I'm hard we got some
fungus in my here something like is it
you I feel good now tremendous stretch
that I got what I had to say up man you
[__]
go out there get what belongs to you do
you understand you make up this thing
you wake up on the Daniel a you know
well what am i doing
you know what belongs to me this life
this is the life I need [__] cause
explosive your own parlor bills up the
strip clubs and that's what you want to
do and you're [__] stealing you going
man you take that life this is what I'm
gonna [__] be and that's it
that's it whether you're black white
Chinese there's no color barriers that's
all in your [__] head
that's what they put in your head see
you sit there and go huh this is what I
am I'm a [__] no you're not I'm a
[__] mug but guess what I don't give
a [__] I got the right to live like all
these [__] you know why cause
I'm an American [__] that's
right even with felonies even if I don't
vote I'm a [__] emerge I feel it in my
heart in my [__] balls today okay you
just don't become a nice like a Jew
everybody wants to pay they just don't
become a Jew a Jew is a state of mind
you understand have my part that state
of mind I don't get the [__] anyway
let's do one more and that's it we'll go
out a [__] day okay
you guys should do I got [__] to do
all right I got it up don't forget next
Wednesday night I'm in [__] Irvine
California at the improv all right it's
the night before Thanksgiving you're not
gonna do it's 8 o'clock kind of clocking
it out of there you get all tuned up and
by 12 o'clock you're [__] a bar
jumping up and down seeing your college
buddies but Friday night I mean Houston
Texas have to come and [__] take it
Comedy Festival 10 o'clock show the
passes of 35 miles but you go to [__] in
God burial 8 o'clock then you come see
me
I [__] Ted who's better than you
that's how I make I make it happen for
you [__] all right
remember for plum today I'm gonna change
your life already I love you [__]
without you and I know gots nothing my
value would be nothing we're a family
always remember that [__] we work
together and we go out there and we take
what's ours you don't steal it you take
it first then if they say something you
say I'm taking Lenny but you'll [__]
yourself alright let's don't this guy
walk ain't [__] around with Uncle Joe
alright
I got a conference cool I love you
[__] alone my aren't gonna take
[__] from nobody at the end of the day
this is your world [__] even Uncle
Joe is visiting it's your world what do
you look at me for all right get your
[__] together go out there don't take no
[__] from nobody and I'll see you
[__] at 4 o'clock ready to go
deep into the murky waters of the
underworld stay black